before you became Cedric the Entertainer
well we were all different things right
but you were such a good claims adjuster
oh yeah how do you end up working in
insurance
oh girl living and I want to see it I
work for state power I worked for State
Farm I was a good company yeah okay farm
you were in good hands how did you talk
to people about their accident oh man
I've considered myself bilingual because
I spoke regular English and angry Negro
that's the black people come in and
threaten you the most about oh you gonna
fix this right here everybody likes Ted
and I like Brooke come here come here
man you know you calm down yeah bro you
people want they cars totaled for a
little of nothing so they can get a new
car absolutely but I was really I was I
was not a good claims adjuster because I
was starting my comedy career at the
same time so I would leave people in
rental cars a very long time like which
was good if you look like wanting to
ride around in a cool new car somebody
might be in a rental car to this day
right now did you enjoy because I
enjoyed some of my previous jobs I
really like some of them it was it was a
good job because I got you know you had
the office and then you would get out
sometimes cuz you have to go around and
see people stuff it like shops to make
sure they were working so that was fun
but then I sold equipment I mean like
electronics for Best Buy that one time
another great job that was I was most
embarrassed I was an adult I graduated
from college but I didn't get a job
right away and I had a paper route I
through the Wall Street Journal and so
like nostalgic and endearing like a
paperboy that's cool
yeah but I was grown out like 27
[Applause]
when it was not but my mother was like
not paying my car is here so I had to
get the money from somewhere I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this